while on a rare trip president vladimir
putin sang the russian anthem with
students and held an open class on the
first day of school
he talked with the children about
fighting in ukraine and visited a naval
institute
putin was in kaliningrad a chunk of
russia on the baltic sea surrounded by
nato countries for putin this little
slice of territory is really important
because it gives him a point
from which he can pressure europe
the region has been at the center of
tensions amid the ukraine war with
russia deploying more military forces
and the transit of goods being disrupted
here's why kaliningrad is so important
for the kremlin
as this map shows kalinigrad is
sandwiched between poland and lithuania
both of which are in the eu and are part
of nato
the former german territory was given to
moscow as a result of world war ii and
it was disconnected from the rest of the
russian mainland by the breakup of the
soviet union
the region is strategically important as
it provides an exit onto the baltic sea
where russia has a big naval fleet as
nato supports ukraine in its fight
against russia's invasion the outpost
has been of growing concern for the west
putin has this jumping off point from
which he can sort of threaten european
and nato members before the invasion of
ukraine moscow deployed nuclear-capable
missiles in kaliningrad following the
invasion the military build-up continued
in august russia said it had sent
warplanes armed with hypersonic missiles
to the region it's essentially russia
reminding the west what it's capable of
and where it has a strategic outpost in
europe
in june anxiety in the region increased
after neighboring lithuania banned the
rail transfer of some goods between
kaliningrad and continental russia
through its territory angering moscow
the region is a manufacturing hub that
imports and exports materials including
concrete wood and industrial chemicals
to the mainland
lithuania has said it was implementing
eu sanctions on russia but moscow called
the move unlawful and warned lithuanians
of serious consequences
tensions were diffused at least
temporarily after other european nations
urged vilnius not to inflame the
situation
they came up with a quota um and so
russia is still allowed to send goods
but every so often we've heard some
quibbles from moscow still that not
enough is getting through
military analysts say the risk of an
actual armed confrontation between nato
and russia in the region is currently
limited
instead putin's visit highlights how
important kaliningrad is for moscow as
the territory is increasingly isolated
in the region what political analysts
believe is by taking this trip putin is
essentially sending a message to europe
he's saying clinton grad is here and
don't mess with it